all good things come with risk
the more worthwhile it is the worse and
more disastrous it will be if you fail
if you take on more responsibility then
your life will be more consequential and
the more consequential your life is the
more cataclysmic your failures
potentially become a married man with
children lives a life of Greater
consequence than a single man with no
children there are more people depending
on him he has a greater stake in the
future this means that if things go
sideways it'll be a tragedy if he screws
up or his wife screws up or they both do
his life will be ruined his children
will be devastated and the impact will
reverberate down through the generations
this is what it means to live a high
impact consequential life these are the
stakes
and yes they are quite High